everyone Bonnie made a friend in class
oh she's already making friends no no
she literally made a new friend
I want you to me four key he's a spool
yes yeah I know four key is the most
important toy to Bonnie right now we all
have to make sure nothing happens to it
woody
we have a situation I am NOT a toy I was
they pursuit salad maybe chili and then
the trash but we gotta get porky a
bourbon
why am i alive
you're Bonnie's toy you are going to
help create happy memories that will
last for the rest of her life
huh come on hi my name is Gabby Gabby we
can't stay yes you can boy what are you
doing here no time to explain
come with me we need to get back to our
kids Oh Sheriff woody you always come in
to the rescue Bonnie needs 40 woody who
needs a kid's room when you can have all
of this Wow
woody are we going to Barney we have to
find only two but what would he do jump
out of a moving vehicle let's go hey you
gotta go you gotta go
[Music]
you know you've handled this lost toy
life better than I could
open your eyes woody there's plenty of
kids out there sometimes change can
because you can't teach this old toy new
tricks if you'd be surprised
Bonnie we're going home for cable
my way what you infinity and beyond
kids lose their toys every day I was
made to help a child remember it being
this hard buddy somebody's whispering in
your ear
[Music]